Wow Wow Minister the Sheep the best you
like the sheets you like them Joe huh
I wasn't listening sorry your whatever
time is what advertisements do you do I
don't get many sponsorships so what's
your what you guys is thing with
McDonald's oh yeah they have beef with
Madonna leader a [ __ ] so I think it's
like an inside joke that we had for a
while because geo said that she didn't
like McDonald's and all of us love
McDonald's so we were just going in on
her then all of our fans just four
months went on their Instagram Twitter
and then just told them sponsor JK films
ah okay I'm gonna ask you I'm gonna tell
you some external dishes I'm gonna like
some of them I like that the best [ __ ]
okay okay that's good
what do you think french fries number
one rated friends french fries out of
all the stuff yeah yes I like something
I think different rates are number one
but my number two is there apple pie
thing oh yeah have you had the taro one
in Hawaii taro what else do you like
from McDonald's Nuggets yes Nuggets in
just regular hamburger because it's so
nostalgic not only that it's so easy to
eat tiny yeah they're small they're not
they don't ever hurt my stomach yeah and
they're just the ketchup is more ketchup
B or something yeah it's really good I
want to eat it tonight
what about breakfast you have a favorite
Oh what's yours I like the sausage Egg
McMuffin boom that's mine too done the
the big breakfast or the one with the
hotcakes and everything oh you like that
one all you do that like a country kind
of a guy del taco taco bell before you
say del Taco you guys have to drive to
the Del Taco and Baker and Barstow it's
different it's the best yes it's
different why it's worth the drive
I'm telling you make their talk so it's
halfway between for you guys to who
aren't the familiar your [ __ ] mind
though is halfway between here in Las
Vegas
two-hour drive to eat del Taco I've done
it I've also driven four hours to a
place in Mexico it's called El original
for some tacos and tortas it's the best
but that's fine like you like I'll give
you an example remember that place that
barbecue place in San Diego that like
feels right is that what it's called
oh yeah it's pretty good yeah yeah I
would drive two hours ago there mm-hmm
right I would drive many hours for
certain foods right try the del taco
why is it different then tacos are
bigger bingling like tomatoes and they
season it a little bit different and the
chicken is really big and chunky and
fresh and the cheese is different the
lettuce is if I don't know why that del
taco is just different it's always
crowded there it's packed because people
know this is the best don't taco in the
country and I'm a big del Taco lover so
you know what it is what did it what is
it what if it says if you think it's Del
Taco but it's not what is it what I
think there's two L's in it there's no a
is that that does how cool the Japanese
cuisine is it del taco yes it is it's
like outside how would they make it no
retro and stuff here's we're gonna do we
do a vlog ready gonna bar and we're
going to Barstow for a [ __ ] don't like
it for reference we should go to one
down the street eat there soft I don't
need to do that because they're [ __ ]
Del Taco before it's wrong
but you have to remind yourself of what
it what the standard is in LA and then
to have one over there well my brother
are an REI are in our parents house this
is what we do we play video games then
we'll go let's go to Del Taco we go to
Del Taco then we go to Target we get
Pringles we get on we get Pringles we
get the little you know mean spy washer
and we make the plug vagina yeah we
foster that and the wheatmore del taco
play video games
you build VP bags together yeah you want
this we should gift it to Joe
I mean oh this is our friend this is our
friend yeah this is Regina you know the
science flashlights before they're not
as good as you can use no I actually
tried flashlights before yes even warmed
up it doesn't feel as good
these dicks what are these 57
multicolored penises that you sent me
yeah and she thinks they're just party
favors she doesn't know either
cuz they're just flaccid penises pull
them out no I know I know she sent you
the yeah you can't stick in your vagina
I can't it's so flaccid yeah yeah it's
dude if my dick was this big oh my god